how can you ensure that your data is
stored consistently
and reliably across a distributed system
my name is whitney lee and i'm a cloud
developer here at ibm
edcd is an open source key value data
store
used to manage and store data that help
keep distributed systems running
etd is most well known for being one of
the core components of kubernetes
where it stores and manages kubernetes
state data configuration data
and metadata etcd can be relied upon
to be a single source of truth at any
given point in time
today i'm going to go over some of the
features of etd that allow it to be so
effective in this way
etd is fully replicated
this means that every node in an cd
cluster
has access to the full data store
edcd is also reliably consistent
every data read in an etd cluster is
going to return the most recent data
right
let's talk about how this works etcd
is built on top of the raft algorithm
that is used for distributed consensus
so let's make a very simple etcd cluster
of only four nodes an sced cluster
always has a leader
and then the other nodes in the cluster
are followers
it's a key value data store so in this
case at key one we have the value of
seven
let's say a web application comes in
and lets the leader node know at key one
we want to store the value of 17 instead
of 7.
the leader node does not change its own
local data store
instead it forwards that request to each
of the followers
when a follower changes its local data
store
it returns that to the leader so the
leader knows
when our leader node can see that the
majority of the nodes
have been updated to the most current
data that's when the leader will update
its own current data store
and return a successful write to the
client
now client doesn't actually have to
concern itself
about which node in the cluster is the
leader the client can make
read and write requests to any node in
the cluster
so let's say this all happens over a
matter of milliseconds
but let's say that the client makes a
read request to the node that hasn't
updated yet
and says what's the value at key one
well this this follower node knows it's
a follower node and knows it's not
authorized to answer the client directly
so what it's going to do is forward that
request and to the leader node
which will then respond the cluster's
current value at key 1 is 17
and so it will get a response of 17 to
the client
and that's how etcd is replicated
so every uh every node in the cluster
has access to the full data store
and it's consistent every data read is
going to return
the most recent data right
scd is also highly available
this means that there's no single point
of failure in the etcd cluster
it can tolerate gracefully tolerate
network partitions and hardware failure
too
so let's say that our leader node goes
down
the followers can declare themselves a
candidate
they'll hold an election where each one
votes based on availability
and a new node will be elected the
leader
that leader will go on to manage the
replication for the cluster
and the data is unaffected
lcd is also fast
scd is benchmarked at 10 000 writes per
second
but that said etcd does persist data to
disk
so etcd's performance is tied to your
storage disk speed
std secure
etcd uses transport layer security with
optional
ssl client certificate authentication
std stores vital and highly sensitive
configuration data
so it's important to keep it protected
finally etcd is simple to use
a web application can read and write
data to etcd use a
simple http json tools
so the other thing to talk about in std
that's important
is the watch function kubernetes
leverages this
so as i talked about at the beginning
scd stores kubernetes configuration data
and its state data
so edcd can use this watch function
to compare these to each other if they
ever go
out of sync etcd will let the kubernetes
api know
and the kubernetes api will reconfigure
the cluster accordingly
etcd can be used to store your data
reliably and consistently across your
distributed system
thank you if you have questions please
drop us a line below
if you want to see more videos like this
in the future please like
and subscribe and don't forget you can
grow your skills and earn a badge with
ibm cloud labs
which are free browser-based interactive
kubernetes labs